why is this for people that are excited
to see the film yet haven't why is this
clearly the definitive version of
Sherlock Holmes clearly the true story
our version is true that's number one
[Laughter]
[Music]
with a musical number right a lot of
people don't know that about Holmes and
Watson
suck on that downy Cumberbatch we're
singing in this one yep yep they sing
and and we're probably I hope that we'll
end up singing eventually like at some
point in the interview not to put a lot
of pressure on you well I'm a huge fan
of show tunes and he's right from rent
possibly it's all about rent control
yeah right we're an issue facing our
nation here today
Lauren break it down for me who is the
best one of the cast at actually solving
mysteries oh wow I mean we faced a bunch
of mysteries when we were shooting the
film obviously like what are we doing
John show up to work today things were
stolen yeah that's true a lot of my
personal belongings were taken never
figured out who did it still troubled by
that yeah yeah you likes to do that and
yeah and then John solved the mystery
and arrested him I was always dusting
for fingerprints mm-hmm marvelous just
in case just in case and it
it's unfortunate that movie sets don't
have HR departments for that reason
right right nobody to report him to yes
exactly right yeesh
something that I realized is that we've
got a guardians of the galaxy cast
member Iron Man 3 cast member yeah so in
the world of superheroes
could you please cast Will Ferrell as a
superhero
Will has already been the superhero Oh
what was that when you were talking
about a mystery oh oh
Megamind you were a villain though you
were like the worst was the worst
yeah me let's make you the best fine
that was animated does it count
I mean you want you're talking to clear
all 25k Disney counts you've done that's
for me
[Laughter]
Rebecca you and John I don't want to
spoil anything but you guys are involved
and I think what is one of the year's
most erotic shared scenes okay so it's
like still suitable for families yup
don't anybody get nervous yeah but I I
wondered if you could tell me about
shooting that scene perhaps like the
energy in the room you know there's a
cadaver that I say and it was our first
season Oh first day of shooting was that
an autopsy love scene you know committed
actor yeah dummy it was not a done
washed down covered in frosting yeah I'm
gonna rub the frosting on and then he
started to get like hypothermia remember
you see it is basically the best
romantic so romantic
it's like anything involving frosting
I'm in so I mean I'm cadavers I mean
it's okay so you read my Twitter feed
cool we have a very erotic chess match
also in the movies takes place in a
dream sequence yeah it does not end well
by the way like it ends on a really
shocking that's true that's true um I
wondered if you guys like had a favorite
book and if there was another literary
character that you wanted to pull from
it to play like ghetto smart for a
second and talk about this another book
first I would have to have read a book
to know the answer
oh my god it's me Margaret and get back
to it we've got a lot of questions from
people that are not lucky enough to be
experiencing this magic in this room I
want to shout out to like Tyler William
Keenan wants to know is this going to
Tyler William Keenan huh yeah three
names even though he's busy in show
business I mean you tell me
Chavez doesn't have a three-part name
Tyler come on out the curtain Tyler
William Keenan he's the father nothing
no Maury Povich fan okay Tyler William
Keenan would like to know will this be a
series or a trilogy
do tell I added the do tell at the end
well TW k
so familiar what do you want to say to
you is it's up to you because you see it
many many many times
joy to all your friends and family you
enjoyed the holidays with this wonderful
cast and then you would will be justly
rewarded so yeah
balls in your court bro
Devon Colson Kevin you could have asked
me this personally just yeah yeah
alright What did he say his neighbors
Devon Colson dressing you guys
specifically and wants to know about
Marion shooting this movie is compared
to all the other times that you've
worked together well this is our fourth
picture together will and I and what
made this Henry frame we've done a video
together oh yeah right to party oh that
but we also did a the remake of Bing
Crosby all right David Bowie will plays
David Bowie of course I thought it was a
drummer boy and I play bingo yeah go
ahead say something Devon I don't know
how to answer this question every
everything in life is different we're
constantly evolving and changing as
human beings right our skin cells are
shedding and we're becoming new beings
every 7 years so it's different every
time man talk to t-dub k he knows he
knows yeah this one of you is like the
Moriarty of the duo oh you mean like
evil and yeah yeah cuz one of you has
one of us we're hunting Moriarty no
here's the thing if you don't think it's
very devilish mmm I came into my trailer
one day and
and every hidden cupboard bathroom there
were pictures of John plastered in a
picture of him I think they were all
from guardians of the galaxy his face
and Wow and then he put at one point
there was a life-size dummy of him used
for some stunts in sitting on my toilet
which gave me quite a start he's not
deadly
by the way this is Rebecca noise seconds
a movie together I did three and I'm in
scene that's somebody grabbing norms
everything again everything's still left
Lauren the the next question is do you
think that other people's portrayals of
these characters kind of had notes of
other people's character which one I
want to segue and I wanted you to talk
about who you are in this yes what can
you give away um well my carrot I play
Millie who's Rebecca's character's
assistant and also sort of research
project and I'm I'm I I think Millie is
a very deep individual with a lot going
on internally and you only get to see a
little bit of what she's thinking and
you have to infer for yourself what
she's going through there's a lot to put
in your pipe and smoke is that what you
would say yeah I did she's often seeing
bugs and things that aren't there yeah
yeah but there's a reason for the
behavior you find out yeah right which
we're definitely not going to spoil it's
a tasty morsel yes
mm-hmm favorite for fans of Sherlock
like as it as we've seen it in the past
do you think that there's any small
thing that kind of carries into this one
that like fans will feel excited about
because obviously it's a new take on it
I mean I think there's a lot that
carries it I mean it's definitely
everything that you know about Sherlock
is kind of woven into this movie so I
think it's really fun for fans of the
actual stories to see this because I
could have certain take that is the kind
of basis of a lot of the jokes in the
movie
I like how ridiculous the Victorian era
was how backwards their views about
women were how crazy their ideas about
science and spirituality were and also
like just very English things they're
very kind of like those very stuffy kind
of uptight English things we have a
field day with all absolutely and and
for fans of Sherlock Holmes themed
pornographic materials specifically the
film Sherlock bones we took a lot from
that you might even see an ankle or to
thank those questions by the way came
from Harold Styles who has to be either
hairy in disguise or Harry's
lesser-known brother mm-hmm by the way
it's not a very good alias my prince
friend just change the first name yeah
you need to work on it brother have you
spelled it differently we know this is
actually this is another really great
huge stuff is not a prince no he's from
one direction
he's a Prince Harry one direction Oh
normally up yeah they broke up yeah nice
one yeah he is a prince but there may be
a reunion tour coming soon are you many
sources say I being for it
sources say me
because I'm finding it one direction
reunion tour hashtags exclusive so this
question comes from someone also with a
very obviously fake name
JEP McNair wants to know oh just think
on that for a second hat yeah mm-hmm so
how do you spell check JEP
just like it sounds it's a juicy one
right really genogram I want to point
out that you both are staring into the
corner of the room very thoughtfully now
you join them and that's exactly the
kind of severity that JEP demands when
asking questions on Facebook I think
just for Jeffry but it's spelled je pH
you just let me determine the speed of
this interview john c reilly yeah Harry
McNair okay so how many yeah no it's
nobody because this is 2018 so but a
sure luck we're here he are we is sort
of sort of he would be he would go this
is smell of ammonia right and shedded
yeah like hair and you would know it was
there someone who's near the actual
question that Jeff everyone Holmes and
Watson he's coming out the same day as
Vice right would you like to declare an
official rivalry with the great Adam
McKay now whoa I would as the number two
in this movie the Vice President to
Sherlock Holmes bring it on Cheney
go bare-knuckle and round around with
you get a new heart and get in the ring
with me cuz I'm ready kaboom which
actually is a great opportunity to bring
up that this movie stars a WWE Superstar
it does can you guys tell me about that
day on set because man did he kick the
movie crap out of you it was wrong as
you're talking about yeah literally is I
think he's 280 pounds yeah it doesn't
make sense when you stand next to me
like that's impossible but it's really
but a lovely human being so excited to
be there so excited to destroy us and
yeah he's um he doesn't mess around what
happens is Steve Coogan's character who
this guy we're looking for in the movie
says like you know I challenge you to a
fight right and then he brings in a
surrogate fighter but which is not fair
wrong who immediately throws dr. Watson
out of the ring and then is it's left to
mr. Holmes to figure out how to fight
him and he really doesn't nuttin gets
back in the ring yeah III bring a
folding chair into the rain and
repeatedly bash him it's like your
character brought a folding chair to a
mountain fight mmm and is brutally
rebuffed for doing so
like the old saying yes the classic
better bring a folding chair to a
mountainside that's what's going on
that's what's going on those are the
first signs of dementia when you say
things like we're just about to the end
of this super fun time with all these
great questions from the audience and
all these wonderful questions from Katy
Perry's lovable you just wrote out the
names that we get to talked about their
names I guess we did
guys know that the game plan for the
interview was just spin him up and let
him go oh wow that was the name thing
was that's my game plan and to fight and
to finally get to that because of the
movie's release date I wanted to present
to you with either things that I that
you can adorn yourselves with or I can
you can instruct me to adorn myself with
oh wow
to celebrate the release of this film
and this is yeah we're just yeah you
know it's a it's all in what bling yeah
they do
John yep absolutely right here because
you know what day this movie comes out
on and then here's it there's a tiny hat
if you wanted to drape it on your really
great-looking real bring a folding chair
to a mountain fight now just sits in a
corner anywheres is Christmas these are
fantastic
these are subclasses I would wear on a
family trip just to embarrass my
children and just play it off cool
mission accomplished
[Laughter]
thank you so much are these are on
straight right because the now is the
point in time where we tell everybody
that Holmes and Watson stole is in
theaters on Christmas Day it's our
present to you yeah you like it we
picked it out for you
I mean we hope you like it specifically
Christmas as they say in the UK I'm just
gonna keep waving
you